what's up Wolfgang as everybody knows
Avengers infinity war is now out and I'm
doing a giveaway giving away a few
copies of infinity war blu-ray to enter
all you have to do is be subscribed to
my channel like this video leave a
comment below with your favorite
superhero from any universe so as I
mentioned in some of my previous videos
the Avengers infinity war DVD is just
packed with bonus features and some of
those bonus features are commentaries
from the directors the writers the
producers etc and it's really awesome
because we're getting a lot of insight
and information that we didn't get from
the movie keypoint the topic of this
video is that we now officially know how
Thanos knew Tony Stark
we actually got commentary from the
Russo brothers who directed the film
themselves so here's the explanation of
how Santos knows Tony Stark
the recent brothers say he's aware of
Stark from the original Battle of New
York as the person who undid the plan um
yeah he sent a giant nuclear bomb into
space and blew up Thanos's army of
course he knows who he is let's not
forget that
Thanos himself is a genius and he's an
expert at Warcraft he's taken over
countless amounts of worlds a guy like
that needs to know who bombed his army
so you can bet that he learned all about
it especially since Thanos was told that
humans were super weak and puny we
learned this in the post-credit scene of
the first Avengers movie where the other
tells Thanos humans were not the
cowering wretches we were promised so
you can definitely bet that after his
army was defeated and a single guy flew
into space and dropped a nuclear bomb on
his army he definitely knows who he is
the question is though how did he find
out about him did he keep tabs on him
himself did Loki manage to tell him
somehow or did the children of fan OHS
do some recon what do you all think let
me know in the comments below and also
let me know what you think of this new
information that we got from the Russo
brothers of how Thanos knows Tony Stark
again infinity war blu-ray giveaway all
you have to do is subscribe to my
channel like this video comment below
with your favorite superhero I
appreciate you watching this video Wolf
Wolf
[Music]
[Music]
you